it's a jobs disaster for joe biden the
president has promised to supercharge
the economy
with trillions in new spending but the
april jobs report tells a much different
story
the economy was projected to add a
million jobs
but we ended up with just 266 thousand
biden is of course spinning the news and
using it to push his socialist agenda
listening to commentators today as i was
getting dressed
you might think that we should be
disappointed
but when we passed the american rescue
plan i want to remind everybody it was
designed to help us
over the course of a year not 60 days
a year we never thought that after the
first
50 or 60 days everything would be fine
this month's job numbers show we're on
the right track
we still have a long way to go
and president biden claims businesses
are wrong for saying they can't find
employees because they're getting paid
more to stay home
do you believe enhanced unemployment
benefits had any effect on diminishing a
return to work in some categories
no nothing measurable
all right well juan that's just dead
wrong just look at the statistics
there's seven million
job openings and only a quarter million
people filled them
how do you explain that
well i think there are lots of reasons
especially we see women
you know uh are very slow to get back in
the market and that could be tied to
schools that we were just discussing as
well as child care issues
but you know i just wanted to say jesse
i don't know how this
is you know pushing some socialist
agenda i mean the stock market today
rallied the stock market was
up today i saw investors yeah they
rallied off bad news our strong cap
because we're going to spend trillions i
don't think it is
because they don't get really bad news
why because they know the fed
is going to pump and is going to spend
but jesse that the the latest
proposition
on infrastructure spending uh the jobs
plan
has yet to be passed it's still being
negotiated so i just think that when you
look at this
i think it's important to understand
that you know
you look at it and and you want to throw
a bad light on it right away
and somehow put down but to my mind i
i didn't throw a bad light on what i'm
saying every news commentator did and
nancy pelosi said it was disappointing
disappointing but in the long term i
don't think i think joe biden is right
in saying in the long term when you look
at this
we see that right now the restaurants we
see them adding 190 000 jobs
hotels and the hospitality industry 140
000 jobs
we see some slow down in terms of the
manufacturing
but in part that's because of supply
chain issues like lumber
you can't find lumber right you can't
find lumber anywhere so
i think these are you know remember that
boat getting stuck in the suez canal
these are larger issues but it doesn't
indicate that we're on the wrong track
the boat in this okay it's the boat in
the canal janine is that what you
attribute the biggest miss in two
decades
still no that's on the other side of the
world but i you know what jesse
i i'll take you out of jail for contempt
and i will tell you this
that i absolutely agree with you okay
and i agree with the fact that the data
proves
the chamber of commerce agrees that when
people can
make more money staying home than going
to work
they're gonna stay home okay especially
people
who say and think that their job will be
there when the money runs out and then
for joe biden to say
don't believe your lion eyes or your
lioneers everything's great
we'll pass his personal infrastructure
we'll get you even more money
we don't expect we didn't expect these
job numbers to go up
hell yeah they did that's what all the
economists suggested and expected and it
didn't happen
so it is a socialist agenda it's to keep
people at home
with money from the government shut
people up in utah i mean you can just
look at everything that's going on
keep kids masked wearing a mask some
kids are neurotic wouldn't have a chance
to even talk about that
and then you know let the economy go to
hell in a handbasket you know the
government will take care of us
yeah lawrence janine brings up a good
point you're getting 900 bucks a week
to not work and we needed that maybe
that 300 bonus during the pandemic but
we got to taper that off or
people aren't going to be able to hit
the pavement well
i think it's a strategy there get drunk
on government depend on us
we're mama and daddy i think ron
desantis
has the best idea you got to take the
money away i mean this is not rocket
science
you got to take the money away so people
can go back to work businesses are
suffering as a result
because the government has become mommy
and daddy and we know how that
experiment
went once before but i think the bite
administration deep down
if they really get out of the
progressive bubble they know they got a
problem as well you had yelling
talking about that there may have to
raise interest rates because of
inflation
wait a minute that's not your job
anymore you're not at the fed anymore
powers made it very clear that they're
gonna keep
interest rates at zero but because they
decided to pump all this money
into the market now we got a problem
with our money
the value of the dollar is a problem
there so i think
if you really look at it on paper the
biden administration knows there's a
problem but they can't admit it because
again they promise all these
progressives all this money
yeah and and shannon biden came out of
the gate and killed two huge
infrastructure projects the wall and the
pipeline
and then he backed the teachers union
which is juan
rightly said has kept single working
moms and married moms
out of the workforce at an alarming rate
yeah it's one part of the stew when
people are afraid when they're getting
government pay and when they don't have
a place to put their kids so they can go
back to work that's a tough
sell to get them back quickly they just
want to mention in montana what the
governor is doing there if you go back
to work if you take a job and can show
you've kept it for at least four weeks
they're going to pay you 1200 so
governors are getting more creative they
want to
try to incentivize it and make sure that
people have a reason to show up
oh you get even more money on top
wow i guess that's why our taxes are
going up all right here we go let's hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else